don't you sound checked yet no not
looking forward to it
i'm terrified half my [ __ ] is good
[Music]
i became involved with sound and metal
through the director darius mada who
also wrote the film
and i was just blown away by it because
it was written with such heart
it was really about the characters even
though it took place in this world that
we don't often see on screen
sound of metal is about the character of
reuben
in relationship with lou they play music
together
loud music they live on the road as the
film progresses he starts to
experience some hearing loss and that
jeopardizes
who he thinks he is search throat
ditch fish but it isn't the loss of
hearing that actually prompts
his story it's reuben's addictive
patterns and
he is forced into a deaf halfway house
it's a space where he's forced to
confront really himself and confront the
silence and the void
my name is reuben i'm an addict i'm
sorry i don't
talk sign language when i met riz we had
lunch together and i offered him the
role halfway through lunch
it was as hard as i thought it would be
but it was also very enriching
learning to play the drums was actually
much more than
learning a technical skill tapping into
something quite primal and something
quite meditative
and learning asl when spending time
within the deaf community
was really profound i learned about
deafness as an identity
as a culture not as a disability and
something to fix
when we were on that set it was
beautiful to see him interact with the
deaf cast
so joe who's played by pool is an
incredible human being both a character
and a human being he's coda was a child
of deaf adults
which means that he didn't speak english
until he was six i'm a veteran of
vietnam
two tours i've had my addiction problems
you know he does a beautiful job in the
role
i've got a little uh assignment for you
all i want you to do
is just sit all i
ask is if and when you cannot just sit
right
joe is all about saving lives he knows
that reuben's life is at stake here
the cure is something external when
you're trying to fix something about
yourself and
healing is something that's internal and
it's about accepting yourself
that's really kind of at the heart of
the struggle
between ruben and joe
i have a seat here
joe is seeing something in reuben in
this scene he's seeing the reuben that
is
on a very difficult path to the deed
the deed
surgery and it's not about the fact that
he got a cochlear implant a cochlear
implant
is a symptom of what rubin's doing which
is an expression
of one who has dealt with tremendous
abandonment and trauma in his life
and has hubristically looking for
a way out a way forward
and away into a place where he won't
have to deal with that abandonment
and all this [ __ ] like what does it
matter what does it matter it just
passes
yo if i disappear like
who cares nobody cares man
seriously you know that's okay that's
life
that's life no for real
okay it just passes just [ __ ] [ __ ]
passes
it all passes what does it matter that's
reuben
and joe knew that so he put him in a
room and he said
i wonder if you've had this feeling i
wonder uh
all these mornings you've been sitting
in my study
sitting
have you had any
moments of stillness why
go into a room and write when you put
that pen to the paper and you just have
to fill a page what happens
is those many things come to the surface
sometimes
that allows us to sit
sometimes we stop running for a moment
we stop
running away from the terror of those
things that we're desperately trying to
avoid in life those
moments of stillness
that place that's the kingdom of god
and that place will never abandon you
and what joe is going to do is he's
going to give him two gifts
the first gift is the gift of this
correlation the kingdom of heaven the
real
kingdom of heaven the real essence of
god that joe believes
will never abandon you because it isn't
outside of you
everybody here shares in the belief that
being deaf is not a handicap
not something to fix and the second gift
that he gives them
hurts joe beyond belief which is the
gift of
asking him to leave joe has been very
clear this is who we are in this
community
this is what we believe in this is
what's important and if you're here
it's important to you too because he
knows there's only one way that reuben's
going to actually
understand this and that's if he walks
down that road
i'm going to have to ask you to pack up
your bags today
and find another place to be open the
heartbreak that he sees is not the
implant the implant is the sum
totality of humans hubris that idea that
we can
assign a fix we can conjure in the
our infinite wisdom a technological fix
and then it will all be okay
[Music]
when you shoot chronologically there's
something at stake
and so riz was saying goodbye to
nine months at that point of learning
asl of being involved with the deaf
community
paul was saying goodbye to that role of
a lifetime that he conjured kind of this
this entire amount of energy for and
saying goodbye to reuben
because we all knew it was over we drove
away from that house after that scene
and it was palpably sad
when i think about that last scene i
always want to thank rose for
breaking my heart i'll never forget
filming it and watching darius what he
was going through he's brilliant
darius is an incredible filmmaker and an
amazing human being and i don't say that
lightly and flippantly i think he's one
of those filmmakers who really leads
with his heart and i think it shows on
the screen
[Music]
we always hope that any film someone
sees has the possibility at least of
changing them a little bit
with this film i feel like it has that
possibility
[Music]